yeah okay we talked about your Mount
Rushmore r b what about of shy town
oh that's good
we gotta have yay of course Jesus
um
that's deep because we got like all like
classical rappers but then we also got
like the new generation I feel like
there's two spots that should not be
disputed it should be Kanye and Chief
Keef Keith has to be because I think
Chief Keef is one of the most
influential artists him both of them but
darcio is also going crazy
exactly it's so hard you know we got
different Vibes like everybody's a goat
in their own right and that's the thing
about Chicago okay but I'm forcing you
to fill out too much no it's all right
okay we got Kanye
then I will have to put common in like
lyrically one of the greatest MCS to
ever live is okay Chief Keef so we got
three yeah and it is one more
can I get a spot on the mountain you
know for the ladies give yourself this
yeah I'm gonna go up too hey shout
out to Chicago please amazing female
artist too shout out to Shawna Shawna
come on no that's big sis what's so
crazy
man life is just like crazy from Chicago
had a relationship too oh really yeah I
feel like they grew up next to each
other they were neighbors it sounds cold
yeah so that's a big sense to me as well
so
shout out to Shawna Drizzy is from
Chicago yeah you know another dope
rapper yeah she's hard her how my hip
was fire okay girl that's my point you
know we got a lot of talent for sure
Chicago's one of you yo listen do you
remember Crucial Conflict I do
of course or Do Do or Die Do or Die come
on man twist it oh man speed not
mobsters
twister was a
for a second in my life Twista
and do or die was like
that heads or tails album or the album
of the penny on it oh my God yeah the
Perfect album damn and then
Crucial Conflict was beefing with Bone
Thugs-N-Harmony about who was doing the
sing song of fast rap first yeah good
times man the Midwest rap Beef Cleveland
versus Chicago